Reuters reports this morning that
Michael Flynn and other Trump campaign
advisers had at least 18 previously
undisclosed contacts with Russian
officials and we're learning that the
Trump transition team knew that Flynn
faced legal scrutiny weeks before the
inauguration the New York Times says
splint old transition lawyers in early
January that he was under federal
investigation for secret work as a paid
lobbyist for Turkey now despite that
warning Flynn was sworn in as Donald
Trump's national security advisor on
January 22nd Flynn was forced to resign
on February 13th major Garrett is at the
White House with more on the story major
good morning good morning the new Flynn
revelations add to the already long list
of White House woes and filling the FBI
director vacancy has become a
conspicuous challenge after two
prominent candidates withdrew their
names the White House was eager to show
its search was not stalled so it brought
in a fresh new crop of candidates
yesterday among them Al Gore's running
mate in 2000 Joe Lieberman the White
House orchestrated this mini parade of
FBI director candidates a bit of
firestorm over the dismissal of FBI
director James Comey adding to that
firestorm block her up now stood
national security adviser Michael Flynn
Flynn reportedly told now White House
Counsel Don Magan on January 4th that he
was under federal investigation that
conversation and another two days later
show the Trump transition team knew
about the Flynn investigation far
earlier than previously reported the
White House is still dealing with the
president's Oval Office disclosure of
highly classified intelligence with
Russian officials we do it for the most
Russian President Vladimir Putin joked
about the episode and called it a little
schizophrenia to quiet the controversy
he offered to give Congress a Russian
transcript of the Oval Office session
press secretary Sean Spicer said he was
unaware of any Russian tapes of the oval
office meeting no politician in history
and I say this with great surety has
been treated worse or more unfairly
seeking refuge at the Coast Guard
Academy Wednesday the president
delivered a woe is me commencement
speech
things are not always fair and told
cadets perseverance is key you will find
that things happen too
you that you do not deserve and that are
not always warranted but you have to put
your head down and fight fight fight
the president has grown increasingly
frustrated with his senior staff and we
are told is now actively seeking
replacements one senior official
described all of these Russia stories as
noise and BS but one outside White House
advisors said dysfunction at this White
House has now reached the highest levels
a significant concern Charlie as the
president prepares to leave tomorrow for
his first overseas trip thanks major